wenn sie es in ordnung dass wir tag
direkt wieder zum leben
aber dabei ich komme zurück
wir kommen nach wartet ihr schon lange
auf uns ja wir waren auch lange sind wir
sind auch die sonne
wieso einem klick auf start
hallo leute und willkommen zu einem
neuen video mein name ist vanessa das
ist kelly und heute machen wir zwei
eisbecher dyballa warum wir nicht keine
dritte person wollten eigentlich ende
teenies problem aber dann auf meinem
ordentlichen ca sie waren unterwegs und
haben zutaten gekauft dann blieb bei
cocktails die bayern machen wir zeichnen
kein eisbrecher geilen amendt 15 zu 2
stimmen thema gemacht wie man auch so
schwer auf auszusuchen
weil man so die chance besser bestimmt
aber sie müssen auch so die mir und
herrn ballack eisbecher origin story
folge ist dann kommen wir auch schon zum
motto meines alters ich habe mich
tatsächlich ein model über
zurzeit stellt seine zutaten vor dem
motto überlegt und cookies und klicks so
heißen als ruhiger stimme brauchen einen
namen länger als kulisse also es ist ein
schokoladen smartphone falls sie es
nicht gecheckt habe das bad sind die
linke oder einmal habe ich hier einmal
hatte ich froh sind wichtige chance sein
und kann das schokosoße die man übers
eis schüttet und dann wird die haftung
000 und davon seine zutaten rote grütze
und roger nämlich einfach immer wieder
gerne reicht es halt gemacht normale
keller finde und der rote grütze es wie
so ein süßes wort für periode 1
das war es nicht doch in kürze ist so
dreist leute ist euch auch so wahr ich
hatte mich gefragt wo freunde also ich
hab ja berlin jerry's kamasutra chor und
hierzu lottosprecher teller
doch das und dass man mal als besser wie
hast du
sprühsahne habe jetzt vorstellt und sein
muss und ob eck
danke wir auch gesagt dass wir das
teilen können
einmal waffeln
[Musik]
so ein cooler marshmallow rose ja cool
blue card guten herzen fand ich von der
schönheit gefühle liebe zu vergessen die
prämien habe ich gekauft war ein pralles
natürlich für ihn denkst du bist marina
kirschen und amarena soße
schokoladentorte die mit arena sein und
für meine alkohol habe ich im mossad
schokosoße ist happy prozent 17
also nicht einfach sherin chocolate chip
und joghurt greco und eben dem auch als
vom straße zeller da haben wir gedacht
[Musik]
ja das will ich deshalb das sind klein
aber die wollen was im ganzen löschen
darf man immer
also ich habe jetzt so ein glas das habe
ich für mein kochbuch benutzt die
hauptzutaten verlassen und darf mit den
beinen und köpfen
man sieht es ein bisschen klein wird
wenn du den 1
wird er auch aber du hast man keine
großen gleich vergeben das ist nicht
schön aussehen die jetzt von heute muss
ich als 20 als cooler wein machen
und ja einigen inneres motto von scheiße
aussieht dass es seine schulden nicht
karriere geführt
mehr hallo hier unten und wenn die
eiskugel da oben das ist geil
[Gelächter]
ich habe gar nichts gemacht wie es
gerade kommt langsam durch
[Musik]
wirklich leute coni probiert jetzt zwar
schlecht und rausgeht aber fertig also
ich fand sie schon ich musste hier auf
jeden fall schon arbeiten flasche wodka
ja ok entnehmen können dass ich schon
hause müssen jetzt was ich habe es
gerade banken
das hat mich auf gewohnt hat der chor
kann man super eis ist hätte vermutlich
mit total format machen wirklich immer
zu zweit
heute weiß ich warum es bei euch nur so
komisch aussieht wenn ihr das macht es
schwer ist eiskugeln schön hinzubekommen
es auch merck & co dgq dicke ding kommt
eine kugel tower
da hast du beschwert sich über meine
kugeln beinahe meine sind wenigstens und
guck mal da mal nicht schlecht und eine
google com ist ein monster kumpel
das macht so sperber so da kommt jetzt
natürlich noch mal ein schuss die
kernkraft weil wir wollen ja dass die
scheiße hier jetzt müssen wir halt und
zwar weil das eis schmilzt jeder sekunde
warum ist dann steht alles nur auf
italienisch sich das leben gibt mein
glück hab ich bitte sie herzlich wie
immer frei so sind hässliche 1 verliert
bin ich inzwischen besetzt da ist schön
aus hier die seite darf man nur angucken
und meine sehkraft von kreativ und
machtpolitisch scheiße den platz kann
ich übernehme ich bin fertig
ich finde diese von dem ihr nicht die
machtclique geschaltet wir müssen uns
schnell probieren schmilzt das ist der
nachteil
ja es sieht auch aus wie eine mischung
aus durchfall mit denen man hat während
der periode mit einer hastigen presse
und probier probieren probieren
probieren ersten unseren eigenen
natürlichen abmachen
[Musik]
meiner ist geil alter meine auch man
muss ja alles nicht von oben bis boden
herne so drahtig verbessern
kein auch wir sind geil ein
geschmacksprofil ist irgendwie meiner
hat ganze mit alkohol und meiner als
gesamtkunstwerke bisschen der doch eher
so ein thema ist alles so er schokolade
ich mir schon so und dann die kirche und
lecker ausgleich dieser mozart das
richtiger liga ich wollte mich einfach
sagen komm wir suchen einfach mega habe
nadal als auch nach der buga likör ist
entgleist
das ist karl menten kam irgendwie
überall alles zu geschmolzen
[Musik]
ich glaube bei eisbechern ist es dann
halt eben nicht alles so mixen wie bei
cocktails weil sonst chronisch
überfordert durch begeisternde dreht
sondern muss heute will ich habe somit
war übertrieben dass man wirklich eine
wahl
und wer gewonnen hat den etat unter aber
schon lange nicht mehr gewonnen
denn mir ist es jetzt vorbei wir
tendieren weißen dass mein großer traum
was hast du da etwa instagram abgebissen
wo man dir auch folgen kann wie auch auf
youtube und erleben ist das lila heißt
so weil auch wie du heißt du kannst du
überall heißt auf allen profilen anders
ich mag es mich zu challenge und ich
mache wenn ich gerne leicht ich will
durch mein konnten überzeugen nicht
durch meinen namen da habt ihr es gehört
leute überzeugen konnte und nicht durch
euren namen northern cali gibt momentan
bei steam edition
william bell
schweiß schwanz schluss schweiz kennt
jetzt wenn man zwischen den schenkeln
schlägt das ist